I was not capable of being a student
because of my deep passion for
entrepreneurship
I thought real quick being thoughtful
about the future is amazing but not
letting it [ __ ] you as the cake I
will make mistakes I am a human I will
do things that are wrong I am a human I
will say I'm sorry when I'm wrong I will
take losses when I deserve them but the
intent is amazing
I gave the 12 best years of my life to
my parents who I loved the most
built them a 60 million dollar business
and walked a 34 with no money need
motivation watch a top 10 with leave
nation
he's Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take
on his top ten rules a success vol 18
enjoy okay let's kick it off with rule
number one love what you do I mean
that's a real entrepreneur she or he
loves it so much they couldn't be I mean
my actions have spoken long before
entrepreneurship was cool I could I was
not capable of being a student because
of my deep passion for entrepreneurship
it was baseball cards it was baseball
cards that didn't allow me to be a good
student I was incapable of sitting in
class and not dreaming about selling bo
Jackson cards it took me over but for
some reason when you're an athlete and
you're missing a bunch of school for
because you're a great athlete or when
you're Beyonce being home school right
that makes sense but not for
entrepreneurs right doesn't seem like
you're allowed to miss a ton of school
if you're an unbelievable actor actress
singer athlete missing Normal School is
something that all of us in this room
and listening right now understand
you're like oh yeah that's what happens
like you're the best quarterback in the
world yeah you got a throw with the
quarterback you miss first class you
know but not for entrepreneurs but
that's who I was rule number two
surround yourself with optimism and
thought real quick being thoughtful
about the future is amazing but not
letting it [ __ ] you as the key yeah
cuz my problem be I would think so first
in the future I always start worrying
about stuff yeah that I want to
accomplish before I leave this earth
years from now that I wanted to do like
oh it's great to have ambition yeah yeah
that's that's when if you cast too much
judgment on yourself on a day to day on
how you're reaching that ambition
you're gonna [ __ ] yourself the fact
that you understand that that is your
perspective means you're on the cusp of
fixing it only thing that I've ever seen
really work in this scenario where your
DNA and your experiences has made you
look half glass full pessimistic versus
optimistically blind is to fundamentally
surround yourself with optimistic people
you got a cut out pessimistic in
negativity and you got to add on
optimism and positivity it's as simple
as that
you guys should be looking around at
each other and whoever else is in here
and like in order who's the most
optimist and not
there's a real fine line between
delusion and optimism I'm gonna be in
the league but they're not even
practicing
so that's delusion I'm gonna be in a
league and maybe you don't see it but
you see them at least doing free throws
5 a.m. to 6 a.m. every morning before
they go on the bus you know at least
he's trying
and it's 10:00 and the more difficult
your circumstances are the more likely
you're around pessimism but my number
one piece of advice of leaving here is
whoever the most optimistic person is
here become more friendly with them
straight up rule number three have good
intent like Gary you're such a
narcissist all your content is you I'm
like I'm trying to say something to
people that I hope they take and I
expect nothing from them I ask nothing
of them and I hope they take it and do
something with it that is the form of
how I know how to communicate it I'm
sorry I'm in the video like you like if
you were trying to get everybody to
watch so that youth everybody here
thought you were the best guy so then
you could rope-a-dope um and get them
into some sort of like $5,000 a month
Club to be good then your face if you
don't and you live your life and you do
it and then you die you're the best I'm
not joking I think intent is the thing I
put my head on the pillow I think I'm
gonna make mistakes every day I will
make mistakes I'm a human I will do
things that are wrong I am a human I
will say I'm sorry when I'm wrong I will
take losses when I deserve them but the
intent is amazing like it's why I'm so
calm it's why I'm happiest it's why I'm
so grateful it's why I'm able to give
because I'm so fulfilled that like I
give out of guilt and gratitude right
like I'm just I know exactly what's
happening with me and I'm trying to get
people to change their perspective but
I'm really not trying to like I like the
feeling of somebody getting benefit from
something you said that's what I'm sure
that gets you excited like watching
somebody go do something meaningful
because they thought it was cool that
you cut somebody like that's an
incredible feeling yeah sometimes yeah
he gives me all the hope in the world
rule number four put in the work
I hear fake manipulations of my story
just one more time because we're having
an on-the-record day I walked into my
dad's business
doing 3.8 million dollars in sales grew
it to a 60 million dollar business see
one-handed it like some other people say
of course not I left the 34 years guys
if I was handed a 60 million dollar
business why would I start vaynermedia
in the conference room of Buddy Media
cuz I didn't have enough money for rent
know what I did unlike all you was I
gave the 12 best years of my life to my
parents who I loved the most
built them a 60 million dollar business
and walked a 34 with no money now what
now what now what so yes people say easy
for you to say that and by the way it's
what everybody does and by the way cool
easy because I have talent that I'll
respect but I put in the work also if
you want to learn how to have more
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link is
in the description below the reason
people aren't patient is they value
other people's opinions too much rule
number five chase happiness I'll tell
you one thing about teaching or anything
else that doesn't make you a million
dollars a year the most upset not happy
people I know have the most money that I
know this we need to start changing a
conversation to happiness not money you
can make 47 thousand a year and have
much more stuff than somebody makes 280
that depends on how much you spend you
might not be in a position to buy every
new off white on a teacher salary but
the question is do you need that the
reality is most people need it just to
flex in front of somebody cuz they're
insecure once you don't give a about
anybody's opinion you don't need you
ain't gonna buy anything you need
nothing
that's straight up man young guys bye
cuz they're insecure they want to look
cool in front of their friends they want
to get a girl it's not super complicated
least complicated of all time
rule number six go on the offense I tell
everybody that I meet along the way that
I think is authentic put your two
fingers in your ears execute in
perpetuity and let the chips fall that's
the only way you'll ever be able to
achieve something remarkable because
when you are doing anything interesting
or game-changing or like different
you're only gonna I've only been booed
my whole life every single thing I've
done basically from school to
professionally I mean I took I don't
know if I've ever taken more heat for
not opening a second liquor store with
my dad like the entire liquor industry
which was my life right my dad's liquor
industry in New Jersey was my life every
one of those people ridiculed the [ __ ]
out of me for selling liquor on the
computer you're pouring all that money
and selling liquor and the computer you
should open a second liquor store right
so like I think there's certain people
entrepreneurs givers politicians there's
millions of people different kinds of
teachers there's certain people who are
just capable of doing that and I think
the reason I talk a lot about it is my
hope is if this one answer can let them
hear one less voice that's moving the
needle because you're either on offense
or you're on defense and dwelling about
other people's opinions of how you live
your life is defense rule number seven
provide value you always get the same
questions your answers are usually the
same what you have a good thing it means
you're staying consistent yep but I'm
wondering how many of these questions
are just self validation question the
longer they already know the answer to
it a lot is that does that trouble you
at all no I don't think when you're
trying to provide value that you get to
decide what the value is that's actually
giving see people don't get it like Gary
Vee you're fully yourself
mmm look a little bit deeper like like I
have no ambition to dictate the value
that I provide
I have ambition of providing the value
the person wants so if somebody wants to
roll up and they need four minutes of my
time
while I'm running to my next meeting and
I'm busy but because nothing gets me
more hype than like bringing humans
value that they need validation even
though I know 92% of time that's
literally what's gonna happen in this
micro moment I'm thrilled to do it
because then if they go do it they start
a podcast and get an interview with me
rule number eight be close to the end
customer you should definitely do that
no no because you need to know what the
you're talking about it's your business
I've consistently stayed consistent on
this which is if you don't know the
craft
how are you judging the people you're
hiring that's different
sure everything else you doing you
should give away good well I just
contextualize it for you how are you
gonna find those seven hours a day to
get great at social your doing something
now I assume like us on autopilot I got
it so what are you doing you should do
this because the products are not the
variable of success the knowledge of
understanding how to communicate to the
end consumer are there's nothing more
important than being close to the end
consumer nothing else matters
there's another big thing that's gonna
happen you're gonna make a thousand way
better products after you're done with
this because you're gonna be in the
trenches and not in a siloed ivory tower
you're gonna have much better intuition
on the product rule number nine
be thoughtful I'm passionate about this
haters trolls thing I think people are
quickly defaulting immediately if
somebody doesn't agree with them and
calling them a troll or a hater and they
they may be but I think it's very I mean
I'm genuinely meanness I take a lot of
heat because I put myself very out there
but I genuinely have become great
friends with many people that [ __ ] on me
or have come to understandings it's very
important you know like to be thoughtful
like look you somebody who might say
you're off and you're just trying to
build a business you don't know if
they're ant committed suicide and that's
like hurt them in their heart and
they're just and you they know you're a
business they knew you before and you're
been entrepreneur you know you don't
know I just don't think we know I think
we're just I just I don't know I'm
getting very passionate about judgment
I'm still in my working stages on it but
like it's crazy I'm just like I have
opinions I'm a normal human being I got
quick I got hot takes on everything but
I know they're both because I know even
the people I know super well even d-roc
who I know super well man do I not know
a lot and so if that's the case the hell
am i doing with your one piece of
content or your one question or right
like you can go on intuition all this
but like I think we need to be more
thoughtful about push back because it's
been very helpful for me like I think I
don't know I think it's important and
rule number ten the last one before a
very special bonus clip is make stuff
happen if you hate your Monday through
Friday you're in big trouble yeah your
big trouble hate Friday
I really do I'm blown away by people
celebrating the end of the week it
breaks my heart my friends like live for
Friday night like they know they got
their wait like Monday morning is the
worst like at its basic form if you
genuinely celebrate Friday you need to
rethink your entire game to live your
life where you love Friday night
Saturday and Sunday and despise Monday
through Thursday or Friday morning is
devastating to me because you're wasting
too much of your life and I'm trying to
put pressure on the conversation to say
if you love Friday that much then you
need to really look at Monday through
Thursday if you literally start your
week being sad and it gets progressively
better you're in a of a problem we spend
way too much time in our lives doing our
jobs when you're spending more than half
your life working it's important that
that thing is on point it's just a math
game if you're spending eighty three
percent of your time 72 percent of your
times sixty-four percent of your time on
something you hate that's devastating
how do people not understand that when
you eliminate sleeping it is what you do
you basically live to work hmm if you're
unhappy where are you going
if you are like running to Friday night
that means you're miserable Monday
through Friday and I lived that life I
used to run into Friday when I was in
school and I hated Sunday night with my
entire heart I lived for snow days for
like a decade like for a decade the only
thing I gave up about was please can
ignore Easter come through and eliminate
school the thought that that is so many
people's work lives which will be the
disproportionate percentage of how they
live their lives breaks my heart
it breaks my heart I'm not making this
video to share how lucky I am or how
cool it is that I love what I'm doing I
just don't understand why people
relegate into losing mentality and just
thinking they can you can't because you
want to be on the bowling team or
softball and play video games that's why
you can't there's plenty of time gets
done now you can watch a little Gary Vee
you get a
you decide to actually work on Friday
night but then you wake up Saturday
right and you're feeling good and then
you grab your phone and you go on
Instagram and the first thing you see is
your boys are the people that you look
up to in the club pretty girls jewelry
money and all of a sudden you're full
mode gout you know motivation is
exciting but the practicality of an
execution is even more importantly and
so I sit here today and I make this
video if I can get one person to be like
he's right like what the hell am I doing
here
Friday cannot be the best day of the
week because if it is you've already
lost and you need to figure out how to
fix that whether that side hustle from
7:00 p.m. to midnight and whether that's
networking from 7 to 9 p.m. with other
job opportunities and whether that's
taking a financial step backwards to
take a job that you love that you can
grow up into please recognize the world
we're living in this is not your
grandpappy's life we have the internet
you can make happen you can build
businesses or side hustles your
grandparents couldn't do the things you
can do your camp Henson didn't have the
internet your grandparents couldn't be
practical 9:00 to 5:00 then come home
you know do their family thing and then
from 7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning do
something online that could have been
the thing that switched them out of
their nine-to-five and created their
freedom didn't have that
we do everybody in this room does we
live in a 24/7 world and people get mad
at me again because like Gary I look
forward to the weekends I love my family
it's not about money you're such an
[ __ ] it's family I'm like no no
you're not listening I'm talking about
if you genuinely dislike what you do so
much that you beg for Friday look and
the only way you're gonna work 15 hours
a day and pay that sacrifice to be away
from your loved ones and travel and
hustle is if you're doing something
around the subject matter that you live
and breathe and die for please take this
permission this energy to start crying
and don't give up be patient please do
not waste the next 5 10 15 20 30 years
of your life and allocate 30 40 50 60
percent of your time to something that
you hear can end each and every week now
I've got a special bonus clip from Gary
on how to ignore the opinions of others
that I think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the free point
landing questions you watch the video
now it's time to take action here we go
question number one how can you provide
more value to your customers number two
what does chasing happiness mean to you
and number three how can you surround
yourself with more optimism the number
one thing that I think about every day
is why do people live their lives based
on other people's opinions
it is fascinating how many people are
dealing with the pressures of what their
parents want them to do versus what you
want to do this blue is right and the
reason you're wooing and the reason that
I'm most fascinated is I am fascinated
by watching parents parent their
children in the exact way that they
hated their parents parented them
it's it's remarkable to watch you would
think somebody who was forced to go to
university and become a doctor lawyer
engineer banker all that pain and
anguish that those years created you
would think that they were capable of
not repeating it but the problem is the
great insight of my life is how many
parents parent their children only and
100% based on what other parents think
about their children
if you want more garyvee check out the
top 50 rules reading I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
and if you don't adjust to the reality
of the situation you will be completely
left behind too many people are
executing